le maire de montréal met fin à une
tournée en europe pendant laquelle il a
multiplié les rencontres au sommet
françois cormier l'a accompagné là bas
une visite assez chargé françois mais
qui s'est plutôt bien déroulé pour
monsieur coderre oui d'un côté le maire
coderre fait parler de lui aujourd'hui
ce n'est quand même pas banal que le
maire d'une grande ville canadienne se
rendent au vatican pour tenter de
convaincre le pape de venir chez lui
d'un autre côté en acceptant de rendre
publics les démarches et bien le maire
prend en quelque sorte la responsabilité
de l'échec si jamais le pape décidé de
ne pas venir au canada
or le mercredi a bien pris soin de
mentionner aujourd'hui que ce n'est que
la première étape qu'il faudrait que
d'autres lui emboîtent le pas notamment
les gouvernements du québec et du canada
qu'ils fassent aller en quelque sorte
leurs relations diplomatiques
je voudrais souligner que si le maire
était satisfait de sa rencontre de 40
secondes avec le pape aujourd'hui il
était tout aussi heureux de deux
rencontres qu'il a eues en coulisses
avec notamment le chef des relations
diplomatiques au vatican est aussi le
numéro deux du vatican
dans l'entourage du maire coderre on
nous dit que c'est un signe que le
vatican prend cette invitation au
sérieux près jean paul ii est quand même
venu trois fois au canada on verra si le
pas françois suivra ses traces mais
avant rome françois denis coderre est
allé en france où il a été reçu avec les
grands honneurs
un maire étrangers reçus à l'elysée ce
n'est pas tous les jours qu'on voit ça
le maire coderre en est très fier faut
dire que tout un contexte qui entoure sa
le maire avait reçu souvenez-vous le
président hollande cet automne à l'hôtel
de ville de montréal alors que le
président n'était pas très populaire
chez lui ça avait été un geste apprécié
est aussi le maire colère avant du
hommage à organiser une démonstration de
solidarité aux victimes de l'épicerie
hyper cacher et du charlie hebdo au mois
de janvier
et ça aussi c'est un geste qui a été
remarquée donc sa visite en europe
arriver à un bon moment il en a profité
pour annoncer un sommet des maires des
grandes villes dans le monde sur le
vivre
semble comment faire cohabiter des gens
de différentes religions de différentes
communautés
il essaiera de convaincre le plus de
mères possible de venir à montréal en
juin comme ça il veut en quelque sorte
démontrer qu'il est évident non
seulement dans sa communauté mais
également dans le monde aura fait parler
de lui il aura fait parler de montréal
merci françois au revoir